when we were in China the dude was like
all right you guys want to get some food
we're like yeah so they're passing the
phone and people just pick what they
want and we got the phone it was all
turtles like the whole thing so it was
like a little McDonald's look like when
you look through nft Collections and
it's just slightly different types
everything's a turtle bro they're like
yeah it's an old Turtle restaurant is
that like their KFC like that's so
normal to them yeah there's like some
kind of restaurant that is nothing but
different kinds of turtles for like
years of scrolling you just got like a
french fry or something when you had
your turtle you ate it like knife in the
fork and you like Fork out the meat from
like the shell you cut the Paw off and
you ate it kind of and it tasted good it
was kind of good but it looks different
Dusty did you eat the tail you suck the
hole um do you want to eat Turtle do you
eat it like the way you suck on a crab
but the the shell becomes soft when they
cook it it's screaming the whole time
they probably braise that it looks like
when people make like a turtle shaped
cake and they slice the cake oh it's a
cake